hello the Internet iron gaff that's moe
and welcome to this quick and dirty
episode of the slow mo guys do to my
occupation I often find myself going
through life thinking oh I wonder if
that would look good in slow-mo and
thankfully I can almost immediately find
out with this high speed camera and
that's exactly what's happened before
the world ended I went to swimming and I
saw that my Apple watch had gone into
water lock mode which is where it sort
of disables all the finger inputs from
the screen because the water affects the
capacitive screen and all that and to
unlock it you spin the digital crown and
it ejects all the water that's inside it
through the to speak holes using the
speaker itself just sort of fires water
all over your wrist and I thought that's
brilliant that's genius I want to film
that in slow-mo so why don't we use our
probe lens on our high-speed camera and
see what that looks like first things
first I will have to go for a swim
water lock okay well that's nice and wet
lovely I'm using the probe lens because
it's macro will get me really close to
the speaker holes which are tiny the
downside is that it's a maximum aperture
of f-14 which is very dark so I need a
ton of light I figured I'd get a shot of
the screen this is 40 times slower and
you can actually see the refresh rate of
the tiny OLED screen from top to bottom
this is now 80 times slower 2,000 frames
a second I was immediately blown away at
how much water actually came out in this
shot it's mainly just because it's macro
to your eye when you're looking at it in
real life it doesn't look like that much
comes out after the initial burst it
actually looks like a lot of the water
gets trapped it's trying to get out but
then get sucked back in by the speaker
retreating so what it does it stops
allowing the water to settle against the
back of the speaker starts again which
causes another burst of water to fly up
it has ten four cycles of it
I think due to the sharp edge of the
speaker hole followed by the the
metallic surface that's curved it caused
droplets to form around the speak holes
which once big enough would just drip
off I think if you were wearing the
watch at this point it would potentially
just get pulled off onto your wrist the
surface tension of this droplet causes
the smaller ones inside just to come out
and join this one I should point out
that the macro lens is making this look
a lot bigger than it is that's actually
a very tiny droplet there the droplets
also able to climb upwards which I
thought was interesting
whichever droplet was closest to the lip
pulled the rest of the water out in that
direction and I saw here as the droplet
was getting bigger it was starting to
pull droplets back in their return or
escape see that one almost made it out
and eventually after the droplet gets
big enough the small ones are able to
catapult free
once most of the water is out you can
get a much better look at the speaker
surface just rattling away back there
shooing a whole video in macro can
sometimes cause you to lose the context
and the scale of your subject so this
shot is just a reminder of how minuscule
these little droplets are coming out
really had to get right in there to see
the speaker just for a laugh I wanted to
see if it would work in Reverse so I
dumped the watch underwater with air in
the speaker just to see if it would fire
the bubbles out and yes it did you can
actually very clearly see the shockwaves
from the speaker because some of the
bubbles that were escapes are still
bobbing up and down to the same
frequency as the speaker I actually
found that a lot more interesting that I
thought I would to actually get to see
the frequency that the watch uses to
eject the water and the fact that it
then takes a break gives it another go
after it waits for the water to sell
very interesting way around having a
watch that has a speaker and also needs
to be water resistant this is not an ad
for Apple I should probably say that
they didn't sponsor this video I don't
think I've ever seen Apple sponsor a
YouTube video be very uh napple of them
wouldn't it hopefully you enjoyed that
video make sure you subscribe and I'll
try and be back pretty soon
with another little how this works sort
of video cuz I do enjoy making them I'll
see you in the next one water lock
you